foreign
dog training book holds out the premise
of the perfect puppy or 10 ways to
assure a good dog but science tells us
that this is all wrong your dog's
misbehavior is telling you one thing and
it's not that they're a bad dog what
it's telling you is how they experience
the world differently from you
understanding this is the key to raising
a happy dog
so I want to make two points to clarify
what misbehaviors actually are
the first misbehavior
isn't misbehavior
it's communication it's information
gathering it's surprise it's excitement
sometimes it's boredom
it's a glimpse into the stage of Life
they're in
for instance
it's communication
barking at a guest
we call it rude but it's not rude they
are telling you something someone is
here
and you're encouraging that
as you go right to the door often
barking back at them in our own way
congratulations you're in conversation
it's information gathering a dog
sniffing you closely isn't impolite
dogs see the world through their noses
up close they are looking at you finding
out about you
their noses have the Acuity to tell
where you've been what you've eaten even
if you've been secretly petting another
dog
it's telling us about the stage of Life
they're in
if you have a dog who's between about
six months and two years old you don't
have as commonly assumed a puppy you my
friend have a teenager an adolescent in
a mature 30 year old body going through
a phase
just like the 14 year old boys sometimes
erratic Behavior
distant or argumentative this phase in
dogs is driven by hormones those that
lead to sexual maturity also have other
consequences like increased sensitivity
to touch and less self-control
the brains are literally being rewired
especially in areas that regulate
emotions and making judgments
you might see more challenges to your
Authority
they might alternate Shine from you and
clinging to you
there might be more chewing of things
chewing in particular may be a way to
help lower their stress hormone levels
so misbehavior isn't best described as
misbehavior at all
the second point is this
what we read as dog misbehavior is
really our misbehavior it's our fault
if their behavior seems wrong to us it
highlights that we have not conveyed to
the dog what matters to us in a way that
they can understand dogs are not born
understanding the sometimes Byzantine
rules of human social interaction or the
rules of our home or what we consider
appropriate behavior
dogs don't have a clue about the
pronouns we give to items that's my bed
that's your bed
or the identities we give to objects
that's a shoe and that's a chew toy
my research has actually shown that even
when we think they know they've done
something wrong giving the guilty look
that is familiar to many dog people
this look isn't a sign of guilt it's a
learned submissive display that they put
on when we're angry so we don't punish
them
and it's actually pretty good at that
often their seeming misbehavior is
actually a poorly designed environment
on our part
you don't leave kids alone with knives
and we shouldn't leave dogs alone with a
cheese plate
if you leave a pair of your favorite
shoes that smell like you
in the middle of the living room as you
leave the house you have designed your
environment to include special use
smelling items in it enrichment devices
your dog will take to it and interact
with your shoes in a way you might find
objectionable
in other words it's on us
once we begin to see that this thing
we've been calling misbehavior can be
more productively translated into what
the dog is actually doing living among
dogs changes for us
misbehavior becomes an opportunity
to see into what the Austrian scientist
Jakob Von of school called the umvelt
the world view or the perspective
of another species
the profound change in my own life after
studying dogs was that it completely
overthrew how I looked at my own dog
chasing a bike it's a glimpse into their
evolutionary history Descent of ancient
wolves with a vestigial urge to chase
quickly moving things which could be
prey
stop the bike and you stop the chase
similarly your dog's jumping on you and
licking your face and greeting
this too can be traced back to their
ancestry a hunting wolf returns to the
pack to be mobbed by packmates in
greeting who lick him or her around the
face
in their case they're trying to prompt
the wolf to regurgitate a little bit of
the food
that they just Hunted
if you don't want your dog to jump bend
down to their height
if you spat up a little of your sandwich
I think they'd be okay with that too
deeply smelling into each other's fur
they're close smelling of us or every
guest
it's a peek into their perceptual
experience
as olfactory creatures with hundreds of
millions more olfactory receptor cells
in their nose than we have
so take them for a smell walk to
exercise those noses
where they lead the way and sniff to
their hearts content
a dog's misbehavior is a chance
for you to learn about this alien
creature that we've all become
accustomed to seeing but who is
misunderstood
when we see their Communications we're
able to listen
when we see what they perceive we bring
ourselves one step closer to dogness
in the end we'll wind up with a better
relationship with our pups
and isn't that what we're aiming for
thanks I think it's interesting how in
your opening talk and really in the book
as well you
the big focus is how we just don't
really understand what
misbehavior in dogs is actually telling
us and I guess what what is your take on
why this is something that's really
challenging for dog parents if you will
versus dog owners for dog parents to
really grasp people who have had
sequential dog relationships even are
still surprised by this I think because
what we see publicly of dogs is usually
very Cooperative
interactions with people right the dogs
you see on the street or when you go to
the park or when you're hiking or
whatever it is are dogs who are kind of
cooperatively going along with a person
as though they completely understand
what this is about and in some ways they
do get to that point where if not fully
understanding what's happening all the
time they are flexible enough
behaviorally to go along with what their
Human family asks and wants to do
but that doesn't happen instantly right
and so we feel giving this appearance of
or even the memory of a past dog who was
so Cooperative who felt like they knew
your emotions and could anticipate what
you were going to do this new dog hasn't
learned all that yet and we feel as
though
that should come with them a little bit
that should come as part of their
genetic makeup
their ability to become sensitive to
human behavior and learn a lot about
humans is part of their genetic makeup
but not the understanding and so it's
it's quite a steep curve to go from
knowing dog to knowing dog and human and
being
like cleanly slipping into Human Society
well I I one thing I also really
appreciate is that the parallel you draw
and I think we we talked about this
before it's just the parallel you draw
between being a human parent and a dog
parent and uh and I'm a fairly new
parent I have an almost two-year-old uh
human human child
um and um and just curious you know what
sort of skills you see that parents can
take from from their experiences and and
raising a dog it's interesting because
um people do talk about raising a dog as
a kind of Prelude to having a baby but I
feel like having a baby prepared me for
having a puppy you know kind of a long
period of no sleep at night you know
where a child is sort of learning to
settle themselves over the night I mean
the same the puppy's gonna do the same
thing
um but if you view it the other way the
more traditional way of the puppy as
Prelude it's having a completely
dependent creature right dogs can get
around on their own but by being put in
into
a home uh I live in an apartment but or
a house
they're dependent on us for all the
things and we kind of forget that right
like we decide when they eat we decide
when they can go out and relieve
themselves we decide when they get to
exercise we decide often it's us
deciding when we want to socialize and
when we need them to be quiet so their
entire life is structured
in this human way this is what happens
to a child as well more slowly over time
because really a new parent as you know
has to kind of restructure their own
life around the baby but the point is
that the baby will eventually be able to
sit cooperatively next to you while you
do your zoom and and and entertain
herself right and but with the puppy
we're expecting basically that from a
non-human and we're also not giving them
several years to learn we're assuming
that they're going to learn it
relatively instantly and always be
cooperative you know and sort of get
what it's all about we really don't the
child at least the satisfaction of
having a child is that they do get it
right you can eventually talk to them
using a language and they can understand
and appreciate what you're saying and
imparting in that language and the dog
even the really high excelling word
learning dogs don't understand our
language and yet we're still talking to
them as though they do that's fine with
me I love people talking to dogs and I
talk to dogs just let's not pretend that
they don't that they understand
what we're saying
this this is a great tips and um and you
should know Alexandra that we are
getting lots and lots of questions into
our members um and so I want to dive
into some of those put those your way
um so we have a question from Ted number
Ann uh they ask I'd love to know how to
better manage a multi-dog household
across three generations 13 8 and 4
years old right that's a great question
and
um congratulations on having such a a
large dog household that's great fun I
think
one thing to realize too when we have
multiple dogs is that
these dogs are still really individuals
right everybody knows that if they have
their own single dog you feel like your
dog is completely special when you have
multiple dogs you still have multiple
individuals and they really have to be
treated separately right each has
probably a 13 year old has preferences
that your eight-year-old doesn't share
some things they'll be able to do
together and cooperatively but I would
expect as often or more often that they
need to have their own time they maybe
need to have their own time with you or
whoever the person is who they're bonded
to or attached in the household and we
also have a couple of questions about uh
language just sort of what you were
saying um earlier that dogs will never
be able to really speak our language
um uh just a question around whether or
not how much they're actually
understanding so both um Ted member
Gordon and 10 member Agata uh this they
have this question around whether dogs
understand tones and gestures and
specifically is uh has a question about
buttons that dogs can press to
communicate in human language whether or
not those really improve communication
and if dogs will even understand what
that those
yeah so they're I mean the dogs are
definitely understanding a good a good
amount of what we say right they learn
words and some dogs are extremely good
at learning words and we know Chaser you
know this famous border collie who
learned a thousand words
John pilley who worked with Chaser spent
eight hours a day every day working with
Chaser so that she would learn
eventually a thousand words and a couple
they were toys and a couple of different
verbs or actions which she could take
with them it was semantically and
syntactically you know unprecedented for
dogs and really need it shows their
capacity but unless you're really
specifically and clearly talking to dogs
eight hours a day about very limited
items your dog is not going to pick
those things up
there's no reason to expect they would
that doesn't mean that there's no
communication already happening right
and I think what the button the the uh
button apparatuses that have gotten
popular and have yet to be completely
you know subject to science and scrutiny
by the way there's no
evidence that those
um
actually represent what the dogs are
thinking or are extending their
communication ability
what they are potentially doing is
though is putting into a kind of
language we understand something that
the dog is interested in but is already
showing in some other way so if I'm a
dog and I want to go outside I can show
you bye
based on you know different different
dogs do it differently maybe barking
bringing you know coming over to you and
trying to get your attention looking at
the door walking over to the door
bringing a leash to you lots of things
like that are Communications If instead
if as a person I ignore all of those
Communications but I also have a button
as a dog which I can push which says I
want to go outside maybe that will get
us to listen but I don't think that
that's something that the dog is trying
to communicate
and can't until they have the button the
best that it can do as far as we know
now is potentially make it easier for us
to understand but I do think that
communication is already present they
are
highly highly skilled communicators and
they understand a lot of what we're
talking about but not
in the kind of linguistic way that
humans think is so important that
enables us to have this Zoom today
um and I think
to to deny them that is not to deny them
the interest in or the ability to
communicate said member Ginger is
curious about the best and earliest age
to start training a dog and also
connects to this what is curious about
your thoughts about electronic training
collars and behavioral training yeah
well so to start with the first part
there I mean as I say I don't explicitly
train dogs which doesn't mean I don't
prepare them to be in human society and
to live cooperatively and happily with
with our family I do that for me that
started with actually socialization of
the dog to other dogs other people and
lots of different types of noises and
surprising things before we got the dog
and that means in the first several
weeks of uh maybe after about four weeks
of their life from four to nine weeks
they're in what's called a socialization
period where they really need to be
exposed to lots of types of situations
that they might encounter later and if
they are then then they become
acclimated to them and that is a kind of
training
right it doesn't it's not like training
to come or training to sit but it's
training them that this is their world
there are airplanes flying overhead
there are people coming out of cars
you'll see new dogs and people and their
cats and their birds and in that period
they react calmly and with interest and
curiosity if you don't expose dogs to
lots of different sounds and people and
things in the first in this
socialization period which usually
extends till after
um dogs are adopted from a litter
then they might be fearful they have
difficulty dealing with those things
they get very anxious they might become
aggressive to those things so that type
of training starts
as soon as you meet them basically and I
think that will lead to the best
solution
as to the second part of that quickly
electronic colors like despise there's
no reason to use electronic colors
or stimulation with any dog ever as far
as I'm concerned it's what it teaches is
that you that they will be randomly
punished you know they have a very hard
time associating that with a behavior
that they just did and this hearkens
back to what I was saying in the talk
which is our concept of what a behavior
is or what an object is this is my shoe
right like that that somehow is going to
be a meaningful important
bit of knowledge for a dog to know that
they shouldn't chew it similarly if
they're just walking along in a property
and then something zaps them on the neck
because they've hit an invisible fence
say
they might learn to avoid that whole
area of the property they might learn
to stop walking they might learn that
the bird they saw right at that moment
coincidentally is something to be feared
you know they don't associate it with
the thing we want them to which is oh
there's a property line around your
property or oh you've just barked so
stop barking right so it's a very poor
learning device and it can also be
harmful
and we actually even have a question
from uh tip number uh Demetrius about
whether or not you can teach an old dog
new tricks um and really what how old is
old but maybe could you share a little
bit more about what development looks
like after that first year we're not
seeing a complete plateau of course but
what do we see right well so most dogs
it's different by breed or mix but most
dogs will still be in adolescence until
about two years old so you can expect
that they will have re kind of reached
their full size more or less Maybe by
about a year it will grow a little bit
more but there's still kind of teenagers
and they're really big strong teenagers
with a lot of energy and so in that
second year of Life often they're still
sometimes really disobedient not
cooperative and impulsive and clingy at
one moment and then and then the next
moment like don't have anything to do
with you right so that continues
there continue to be socialization
opportunities I said there was a strong
socialization period where you want to
expose them to things that they might
encounter later in life so that they
have the best interaction with them that
still is the case just to a lesser
degree through their second year where
their uh brains are still changing right
just like the Adolescent brain of a
human the Adolescent brain of a dog is
still in development until that time
after that time they're adults and I
think here the analogy to humans is
is apt right they can absolutely learn
new things but sometimes they're slower
to learn new things exposure to a new
environment might take multiple stages
if they're a little bit fearful or a
little bit anxious rather than just
being able to waltz into a new
environment
and accept it right because that's just
the way the world is so things have to
have to learning happens maybe at a much
slower Pace but absolutely happens and
that's learning can happen up till
the end of their life you know I think
it was in the last few months of our
dog Finnegan's life who lived to 14 and
a half that he suddenly started really
getting interested in um puzzle toys
where food is hidden under little
compartments and you sort of have to
turn a lever to unlock the compartment
and open up the compartment and
he encountered that at age 14 right he
wasn't as quick at it as he would have
been as a puppy but he could learn that
without a problem he took up nose work
which is a kind of game of sniffing and
finding things by smell alone
when he was about seven
and he took it up you know with alacrity
so
absolutely keep stimulating them that
there is research now happening on the
Aging canine brain and like the Aging
human brain it needs uh stimulation to
continue growth versus atrophy it sounds
like also some of the reasons dogs maybe
are have been returned has to do with
this misunderstanding about misbehavior
or what um the things you're suggesting
here that we just don't really
understand why dogs are behaving the way
they are and see it as perhaps uh
um an inconvenience or challenge instead
of an opportunity to to interact with
your dog differently right yeah I mean I
think they say challenge it's such a
great word to use right there's a huge
amount that's challenging about asking
an animal to come and live cooperatively
and neatly and tidally and with full
understanding in your home and the fact
of that shouldn't be so amazing but I
think it's still often overlooked
um and yeah in particular adolescence
this time when oh you thought you taught
your dog you know the rules of the house
or everything you they need to know for
a little bit of that Cooperative
cohabitation to happen
suddenly you seem out the window and
your dog is just running your mug and
being disobedient and so forth that is
when most dogs are relinquished to
shelters
um the authors of a great book on
adolescence called wildhoods say like
essentially
you know in that case with a case of
dogs often adolescence is a death
sentence because if the dog misbehaves
and the person gives up the dog then
they might wind up being euthanized
through no fault of their own because
simply
we have too many dogs right
um I think it really behooves us as a
society to know a little bit more of
this going in right I don't want to
de-romanticize
the pleasure of living with dogs but I
want people to come in with their eyes
open realizing that these challenges are
ahead and on the other side of that and
even through the challenges
um is that satisfying relationship that
they're looking for
Ted member Gloria is curious if dogs
perceive color
right absolutely good question Gloria
because for a long time it was assumed
that they did not
um and that was based on poor science
essentially but they can see in colors
they have two color vision versus our
three color vision so we have cones for
three different Hues and they have cones
for two different Hues so
uh they won't distinguish clearly Reds
and oranges and yellows
um and we don't know exactly what they'd
look like probably a little bit like
adjoining colors
um
so for instance if you ever go outside
when it's Dusk and you notice that like
the colors seem muted a little bit our
guess is that that's more or less what
their color vision is like but they're
perfectly able to see color they also
have great
um other visual abilities like you know
they they see motion much more quickly
and readily than we do so to make and
they see well in low lights and they see
well at night so their eyes are really
adapted to do something a little bit
different than our three color vision
eyes are
and then Ted member um Arya is curious
why um do our dogs smell our breath oh
it's great information about us um in
fact there there have been there are now
studies using exhaled breath
um
to ask dogs whether they can determine
which exhale includes cancerous notes uh
to distinguish
subjects who have lung cancer from those
who do not so but there is a lot of
information in your breath um not just
about
um what you've eaten recently but also
about your health especially right so uh
and you know in fact doctors human
doctors used to use smell as a
diagnostic material much more until
about the 20th early 20th century and
you know the smell of a diabetic
um is is especially sweet for instance
and so just by smelling the breath of a
patient could potentially get some more
information about whatever was
concerning their patient and dogs can
smell that do they know that's diabetic
no but do they know if something's
different than before you ate something
different or maybe you're sick maybe you
have a cold they might be more
interested in your breath I always pay
attention if my dog is particularly
interested in my even morning breath
interesting wow they're it's it's their
way of helping out
um yeah if you listen to that they're
probably saying something even without
the overarching knowledge what's behind
it yeah well sort of along those same
lines we have an anonymous attendee who
also asks why does their dog eat their
own poop
um is is this
um kind of curiosity are they doing it
to get a reaction or is there something
bigger happening there are lots of
theories about this this is called
copper fascia and it's not uncommon so
your dog is not doing something wildly
abnormal
um sometimes dogs will eat feces their
own or others because there is a
nutrient deficiency in their diet
um I mean it is actually full of
nutrients still because we and dogs pass
a lot of nutrients that we just haven't
digested
so there might be something deficient
um some dogs will do it to remove
evidence of their own odor so actually
you know the way that dogs will
pee to and it leaves in an effect leaves
their odor and they might even pee
conspicuously on a high post or tree
trunk or light Lamppost in order to have
their odor smelled by other dogs
um feces excretion excreta can also
be that information but if you for
instance didn't want to leave your
information in a location a dog might
for whatever reason there was another
dog nearby who you didn't want to have
an encounter with
they might consume uh their feces if
they'd been previously punished
for um pooing maybe they would eat their
feces but you know there are lots of
possibilities I can't tell exactly but I
would always always check with your vets
and see if there's anything that they
might be missing in their diet that
maybe they're trying to make up for
themselves
Paul Alexander you have shared so many
really fascinating helpful
um there's just great information with
us um during this conversation and just
as we're starting to wrap up here is
there you know one thing I think of the
things that you've shared here that you
feel like if you take nothing else from
this conversation that you hope uh folks
will will be able to use in their lives
and their relationships with their dogs
I think the hardest thing for people to
realize about their dog who is looking
you in the eyes and
following your gaze and walking by your
side and such a loving companion is that
they exist in this parallel perceptual
world of smell which we don't spend a
lot of time in or even try to avoid
and every dog who I've seen who is
allowed to live in that world a little
bit more sniff things they want to sniff
intentionally go out for smell walks
um is a happier dog and I think the
people wind up more satisfied in
understanding what their dogs are doing
as well so
um glad you take your dog for a small
walk that's my that's my final
word
[Music]